good God Almighty you know they put
themselves in danger girls like that
[Music]
you think you'd mind by that age right
ladies lay down what are you two ladies
okay hey yourself
what are you doing Hey
I said what are you doing
[Music]
every week I go to a club I act like I'm
too drunk to stand and every week a nice
guy comes over to see if I'm okay okay
who are so pretty I am a nice guy are
you so we have a connection okay how old
am I
what are my hobbies what's my name
sorry maybe that one's too hard
Casandra we're in class together at
forest you would have been the great
doctor what happened
I left under unusual circumstances you
remember what happened right why I
dropped down I'm not the only one didn't
believe it we get accusations like this
all the time you need brains
they never did a girl any good I'm so
sorry I didn't go with her you gotta let
it go
what are you gonna do
[Music]
everything we were kids if I hear that
one more time I have to give him the
benefit of the doubt I was hoping you
feel they're friendly by now it's every
guy's worst nightmare getting accused
like that
can you guess what every woman's worst
nightmare is I wanted to be a doctor my
whole life
[Music]
lately I've been feeling like I might
want to get back into it
you